وصل الرئيس الايتواني جيتا ناس نوسيدا الى
كييف وقال ان بلاده ستشتري منظومتين
صاروخيتين من طراز نسمز المضاده للطائرات
لصالح اوكرانيا
هذه الانظمه في اقرب وقت ممكن واوضح انه
تم توقيع على هذا الاتفاق بين التوينيا
والنرويج والشركه النرويجيه المنتجه لهذه
الصواريخ
في واشنطن اعلن البيت الابيض ان حزمه
المساعدات الامريكيه الجديده ستدعم عمليات
الهجوم المضاد وقالت نائبه المتحدثه باسم
البيت الابيض اوليفيا دالتون ان الحزمه
ستعزز الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه للتصدي
للهجمات الصاروخيه الروسيه
اداره بايدن تعلن اليوم عن حزمه مساعدات
امنيه جديده لاوكرانيا حيث نواصل الوقوف
الى جانب شعبها ضد الغزو الروسي الوحشي
الحزمه تتضمن قدرات اساسيه لدعم عمليات
الهجوم المضاد وستعزز الدفاعات الجويه
لمساعده اوكرانيا على التصدي للهجمات
الصاروخيه كما اكد الرئيس بايدن لنظيره
الاوكراني يوم الاحد فاننا سنواصل دعم
كييف وهي تدافع عن سيادتها ووحده اراضيها
ضد العدوان الروسي
من جهتها قالت السفاره الروسيه لدى
الولايات المتحده ان حياه الاوكرانيين لا
تعني شيئا للسلطات الامريكيه واضافت ان
الشحنات الجديده من المنتجات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا تؤكد فقط هوس واشنطن بفكره
الحاق هزيمه استراتيجيه بروسيا لهذا تقوم
بدفع رعاياها الى مزيد ومزيد من المغامرات
اليائسه على حد وصفها